en afrique la côte d'ivoire a entamé son
déconfinement avec la réouverture des
écoles comment le pays gère-t-il la
rentrée scolaire
éléments de réponse avec ballon tant
qu'art porte chez sur des images ne
correspondant sur place cet après midi
les membres de la famille quoi s'y
prépare le retour à l'école de leur fils
aîné élèves en cp dans un établissement
public du quartier d'angré à abidjan
dans 48 heures le petit dylan retournera
en classe après deux mois de confinement
une reprise attendue mais pas sans
inquiétude
l'épidémie de coronavirus est toujours
dans les esprits et les parents ont des
doutes sur les conditions d'accueil de
leurs enfants
pour moi un enfant je suis très inquiet
et même trop peu inquiet parce que c'est
il est aussi peu d'eux il bouge beaucoup
déjà en plus de cela c'est peu d'eux
rime avec enfin à bas âge enfin en bas
âge il ne maîtrise pas vraiment ne
connais vraiment pas le risque qu'il ya
à se faire contaminer par ce virus est
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir comprenait les
enfants passer les infos du bilan les
affole bouge beaucoup
cette île voilà m s et al mais est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir les gérer
malgré ces craintes de nombreux
établissements scolaires ont déjà
rouvert dans le pays
c'est le cas de l'école primaire gabriel
dadié dans le quartier de koumassi au
sud d'abidjan pour permettre cette
réouverture
le directeur a dû mettre en place
plusieurs mesures barrières gel
hydroalcoolique lavage systématique des
mains ou encore le port du masque
obligatoire
tout a été mis en oeuvre pour l'accueil
des élèves dans les meilleures
conditions sanitaires une rotation a
même été mise en place pour limiter les
effectifs des classes à 35 enfants au
lieu de 70 habituellement ce bond dont
le directeur a du mal à faire respecter
les gestes barrières et des pleurs un
réel manque de moyens non non non ce
n'est pas suffisant voilà pourquoi j'ai
d é espère que le gouvernement fait
l'effort de nous doter encore par
semaine parce que le cas ce n'est celle
d'avant ne faut pas faire une deux ou
donc ou bien les parents seront obligés
à chaque fois et même des comptes et la
russie ont mis à contribution pour qu'on
puisse à apporter les fresques ont fait
goûter les enfants des cache-nez
réutilisables
à l'école primaire publique pilote
d'abidjan on trouve des parades pour
remédier à ce manque de moyens en plus
des mesures barrières habituel la
directrice de l'établissement a décrété
une nouvelle règle la suppression de la
récréation en extérieur à l'heure de la
pause
une démarche drastique qui vise à éviter
tout contact entre les élèves
ap non je pense que cela cesse et la
même façon si non pourquoi pas les
canaliser dans la première fois qu'on en
dise on pourra pas les canaliser 17
manioc ouais on a eu nos élèves les
enfants principaux concernés par ces
mesures vont devoir s'habituer à ces
changements afin d'éviter au pays une
crise sanitaire semblables qu'ont connu
les pays les plus riches de la planète